und es gibt neuen zoff um die basken
pflicht im flugzeug die könnt ihr jetzt
nach bild-informationen sogar noch
verschärft werden am morgen im kabinett
das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz und da wird in
der regierung jetzt diskutiert das mit
flieger künftig keine normale
medizinische maske mehr ausreicht
sondern dass es künftig zwingend einer
fft zwei maske sein muss ja nach
bild-informationen also könnte die
regierung die masken pflicht dem
flugzeug jetzt sogar noch verschärfen
das ist wirklich ein hammer denn dieser
regierungsplan der wirkt absurd
angesichts der bilder die wir in den
vergangenen stunden gesehen haben
kanzler und minister im
regierungsflieger scholz & harbeck auf
ihren regierungs flug nach kanada ohne
maske und das entspricht dort im
regierungsflieger auch den regeln dort
nämlich gibt es keine masken pflicht
warum geltender andere regeln als in den
urlaub fliegen haben sich millionen
deutsche gefragt und dann war eigentlich
lag es auf der hand dass man dann sagt
na gut wenn dieses nicht brauchen da in
ihnen regierungsflieger dann schafft man
es jetzt ab dann ist die masken pflicht
überall in allen flugzeugen erledigt
geschichte das gegenteil offenbar
passiert jetzt vertreter jetzt schauen
wir mal rein in unsere urlaubsflieger
nämlich da sieht es nämlich so aus maske
beim einsteigen beim aussteigen und das
wichtigste während des gesamten fluges
muss die maske an bleiben wir
medizinische maske bisher und herz eben
der plan ich nenne ihn mal lauterbach
plan es wird diskutiert am
kabinettstisch in der regierung ob man
das eben noch mal verschärft weg von der
medizinischen maske und dann tatsächlich
auch für alle die da drin sitzen die ffb
zwei maske auf das also der plan morgen
ist kabinett das heißt es könnte dazu
kommen dass scholz und habeck im
regierungsflieger ohne maske
zurückkommen von ihrer kanadareise sich
dann am kabinettstisch setzen und dann
sozusagen die unterschrift machen über
eine verschärfung der masken pflicht für
alle anderen fluggäste in deutschland
die nicht im regierungsflieger sondern
im urlaubsflieger er viele regt das ist
natürlich total auf viele von ihnen
liebe zu schauen und zuschauer aber auch
in der politik ist schon einige stimmen
die sich darüber aufregen schauen wir
mal direkt rein in eine solche stimme
auf twitter geht es nämlich hoch her
alexander graf lambsdorff beispielsweise
der twittert dass hier er sagt ganz klar
man muss nicht masken gegner sein dann
kann man bin ich nicht oder
fdp-politiker gut bin ich es reicht
demokrat und staat bürger zu sein um zu
wissen nach diesen bildern kann es nicht
bei der massen pflicht enorm ein
flugzeug bleiben wir haben die masken
stimmungs check gemacht heute früh am
flughafen unsere reporter dort im
einsatz und haben ihnen einfach mal die
bilder der aus dem regierungsflieger
gezeigt und sie gefragt mensch wenn die
nicht mehr tragen müssen dann müssen sie
jedoch auch nicht mehr oder
nur scheiße dann sag ich mal auf deutsch
ist
unmöglich von 49 fordernd und hier sind
ja tolle vorbilder kann man ganz sicher
sein mir fehlt einfach nicht die worte
da wir den bürger wird aufgelegt ja wir
sollten vorsieht dieser positiv sein
schätzt eure mitbürger ja eure nachbarn
ja und unser
oberster heute blickt jan eder macht ja
nichts das ist die regierung so ist es
heute morgen so na ja es hat mit
zweierlei maß gemessen also eine maske
tragen müssten dann wär's ja nicht
lächelnd ja auch eine tragen wie man
dadurch wahrscheinlich klasse eins aber
da wären sie wahrscheinlich nicht so in
kontakt kommen mit denen anderen
passagieren absolut nicht in ordnung
geht gar nicht ist doch kein gutes
vorbild für seine persönlichkeit der ist
dann wahrscheinlich falsch in seiner
position muss ich ganz deutlich sagen
hast du das werden auch nicht sagen wenn
man nicht trägt oder
also wir haben schon raus das empfinden
sie natürlich nicht alles richtig wenn
er politik oder maske fliegen darf und
wir alle nicht aber würde es denn
überhaupt sinn machen diese regel noch
zu verschärfen also im flieger dann nur
noch mit sp2 maske dass er mit denen der
biologen tauscht er gefragt
wir haben gerade erfahren dass im
kabinett gerade diskutiert wird die
masken pflicht in fliegern sogar
nochmals zu verschärfen also für uns
normal flieger für uns urlaubsflieger
soll möglicherweise die medizinische
maske gar nicht mehr ausreichend da soll
die pflicht noch mal verschärft werden
auf ft2 maske herr stöhr wenn sie das
jetzt vergleichen an demselben tag
fliegt der scholz mit dem harbeck ohne
maske alle journalisten mit drin auch
wir von bild waren damit an bord schön
ohne maske und jetzt wird uns noch mal
gesagt die wir auch ohne maske fliegen
wollen das wird möglicherweise noch
einmal verschärft für den herbst ja das
hat ja vielen ebenen keinen macht keinen
sinn mehr in den spielern gibt es einen
außerordentlich hohen luftaustausch gibt
es sogenannte die in den fliegern sogar
ihren herausfiltern können also in den
fliegern masken zu tragen ist ansich
unsinnig weil eben diese sehr gute virus
zirkulation dort wieder sehr gute luft
über das bier und natürlich die
ungleichheit in der behandlung ist
natürlich schon völlig ja zum corporate
zum kopfschütteln an und dann kommt noch
mal dazu dass die luft stand sei ja eine
der ganz ganz ganz wenigen airlines die
noch die masken pflicht dass es mit zwei
masten und das verlangt also ist es auf
vielen ebenen überhaupt nicht mehr
nachvollziehbar es geht in der gegner
diese situation ja nicht mehr darum
infektionen zu verhindern sondern die
schweren verläufe wurde dass die o2 wird
bei einer population masken in den
flugzeugen machen keinen sinn mehr für
nächsten sommer in der relativ
entspannten situation
auch nicht einfach meinem blickwinkel in
den fernverkehrszügen da gibt es nämlich
klimaanlagen wir haben auch ein großteil
der filter sehr gute luft umtausch dann
hat man keine masken in den bussen wo
eigentlich etwas stickig ist warm also
es passt also nicht systematisch ist
nicht konsequent es ist nicht durchdacht
die zielstellung ist unklar also das
passt hinein in diese irgendwie
situation
sagt klaus stöhr biologe uns
zugeschaltet vielen herzlichen dank für
ihre zeit und für ihre informationen
[Musik]